good morning Hank it's Tuesday well this
is a nice turn of events they're
decorated I think I haven't been getting
a lot of sleep lately and as you can
probably tell puff flows are a little
bit high but I don't want to talk about
that today I want to talk about my
favorite subjects for those who are
unaware reddit is a link aggregation
site with lots of different communities
called subreddits and while I often find
browsing an uncreated reddit to be a
little bit unpleasant and at times even
kind of toxic there are also many
wonderful corners of Reddit including
for the record reddit.com slash are
slash nerdfighters where you can follow
along with all the happenings in
nerdfighteria okay first we have
children falling over which is just a
collection of mostly wholesome gifs of
children falling over I mean who among
us does not want to watch this kid fall
off a diving board over and over and
over again
and speaking of over and over and over
another of my favorite sub reddits is
better every loop which is a collection
of gifs that get better with every loop
an example being this jiff entitled four
girls one rat in which a group of young
people devise a brilliant and
complicated strategy forbidding their
home of a rat wait wait for it wait for
it yes oh I could watch that again and
again but alas we can't cuz we have to
move on oh no wait I just realized that
I've already said gifs several times in
this video so everyone's gonna be mad at
me for my pronunciation and flame wars
are gonna erupt in the comments even
though for the record both
pronunciations are entirely correct in
fact I'm just gonna use both
pronunciations to make sure that I
infuriate everyone right okay let's move
on to birds with arms which sounds like
some kind of weapons related euphemism
but in fact is a subreddit devoted to
birds with arms they got like owls with
arms roosters with arms armed Hawks with
arms basically all of the major birds
but with arms somewhat more
sophisticated is the subreddit Internet
is beautiful which introduces you to
beautiful websites all around the world
from one that allows you to listen to
live radio anywhere on the planet to a
website where Google's AI tries to guess
what your doodles are basically it's
like playing pictionary against Google
and it turns out that Google is very
good at pictionary that AI still can't
figure out which videos to D monetize
but it's great at pictionary also in the
is beautiful category data is beautiful
a subreddit that shares interesting and
beautifully presented data like this web
tool exploring which countries are
emitting the most carbon and from what
sources then we have RuPaul's Drag Race
which is full of screenshots and fan art
and gifts about the best reality TV show
currently
the air another of my pop-culture
favorites is the subreddit Empire did
nothing wrong which is devoted to the
fan theory that in the Star Wars
universe the Empire is actually good and
the Rebel Alliance are the bad guys okay
let's move on to nature is effing lit
but with the actual curse word the
subreddit explores all the ways that
nature is you know effing lit like this
crab using two sea anemones to protect
himself they're also great collaborative
communities on reddit like reddit gets
drawn where people submit photographs
and then other people draw them so that
this dog for instance becomes this and
this and this that just makes me happy
as does oddly satisfying a community
devoted to images into animations that
are oddly satisfying like this one is
called double dominos and at first
you're like yeah I don't know that's
reasonably satisfying but then if you
just wait for it for a second oh now
that that is oddly satisfying I also
love the subreddit imaginary maps as
readers of paper towns will be
unsurprised to learn it does contain the
occasional copyright trap map but it's
mostly somewhat fantastical maps like
majority language spoken at home in the
republic of skyrim or really fantastical
maps like New York State high-speed rail
2030 and lastly there is a very weird
subreddit called high quality gifs in
which people devote many many hours to
creating astonishingly stupidly
high-quality gifts and even more weirdly
almost all of them are so-called
meta which is to say that they are
mostly gifs about gifing or possibly
gifts about chipping high-quality gifs
is one of those places where the longer
you hang around the better it gets and
that's my favorite kind of Internet
community in fact it's the kind I hope
we have here okay Hank I have to get
back to work but at some point I will
need a break so I hope you let me know
in comments what your favorite corners
of the Internet are on reddit or
elsewhere hank dftba I will see you on
Friday